welcome back to CBS this morning the top
Democratic presidential contenders came
out swinging in a fiery contentious
debate in Las Vegas last night former
New York City Mayor Mayor Mike Bloomberg
was on stage for the first time after
surging in recent polls it took just
seconds for his rivals to take him on
I'd like to talk about who were running
against a billionaire who calls women
fat broads and horse-faced lesbians and
no I'm not talking about Donald Trump
I'm talking about Mayor Bloomberg we are
giving a voice to people who would say
we are sick and tired of billionaires
like mr. Bloomberg seeing huge
expansions of their wealth while a half
a million people sleep out on the street
tonight I've been told many times to
wait my turn and to step aside and I'm
not going to do that now and I'm not
going to do that because a campaign memo
from Mayor Bloomberg said this morning
that the only way that we get a nominee
is if we step aside for him Bloomberg
was attacked on a variety of issues he
had a tense exchange with Elizabeth
Warren after Bloomberg said he would not
release former employees from
non-disclosure agreements related to
alleged harassment and discrimination so
mr. mayor are you willing to release all
of those women from those non-disclosure
agreements so we can hear their side of
the story
we have a very few non-disclosure
agreements
how many let me finish how many is there
none of them accuse me of doing anything
other than maybe they didn't like the
joke I told and let me just put and let
me play there's a agreements between two
parties that wanted to keep it quiet and
that's up to them they sign those
agreements and we'll live with it senior
political analyst and 60 minutes
correspondent John Dickerson is here as
well along with CBS news political
contributor and Democratic strategist
Joel Payne good morning to both of you
so I think last night's debate was more
of a bar fight than we'd see in Pryor
and Michael Bloomberg seemed to walk
into the bar not expecting quite the
fight he got how do you think it'll
affect his campaign
yeah they slammed the door at his coming
out party and then he had trouble
opening it again you know one of the
challenges when you're when you're a new
candidate is taking the incoming and
then diffusing it and then saying this
is what I'm for he'd never got that
opportunity never took or seized that
opportunity and if debates matter they
mattered in New Hampshire when Amy
Klobuchar rose when she had a good
performance
if debates matter this was not a good
night for is it going to matter do you
think I think that's a lot to be
determined because if you look at the
early vote there's over a million people
who voted early in California there's
over two-thirds of the people were going
to vote Nevada have already voted so
this was a good night for Elizabeth
Warren it was probably a good night for
Bernie Sanders it probably was a bad
night for Mike Bloomberg but how much
does it affect them in the long run
we'll see we only had to know those
questions were coming I think that's
what everyone is talking about today he
knew the in date NDA questions were
coming about women and about certainly
about stop-and-frisk what do you think
happened it's been such a long time
since someone's probably challenged Mike
Bloomberg on stage I mean it's been ten
years since his last debate he's not
used to as a billionaire having people
challenge him and come at him and
directly challenge his authority I think
it felt like he was running 20 miles an
hour and everybody else is running 75
miles an hour
he literally sits felt like a visitor on
the stage last night it didn't feel like
he was a part of the party I'm sure he
feels like he's a part of the party
right now Elizabeth Warren didn't feel
like a visitor did she reveal a lot
revitalize her campaign after a couple
of disappointing finishes she was she
basically checked every box she was both
on the attack she was then generous when
she jumped in to defend Amy Klobuchar
you felt like if a light blew out this
Oh she'd climb on a ladder in fixes she
did everything in that debate now the
question is does that does that help her
campaign we'll have to see the wonderful
thing is the voters get to make their
decision but she was really really came
to play and if iron sharpens iron it was
a real benefit for her to have Michael
Bloomberg there because they wield on
stage the kind of person she's been
essentially attacking and hurt one of
the questions well when we get to some
sound because one of the questions
coming into this debate was do voters
want a billionaire in the form of
Michael Bloomberg or do they want an
anti a billionaire in the form of Bernie
Sanders who says billionaires should not
exist let's look at it exchange between
the two of them they talk about a
grotesque
and immoral distribution of wealth in
income Mike Bloomberg owns more wealth
than the bottom a hundred and twenty
five million Americans that's wrong
that's immoral Mayor Bloomberg should
you exist I can speak for all
billionaires all I know is I've been
very lucky made a lot of money I work
very hard what we need to do to deal
with this grotesque level of income and
wealth inequality is make sure that
those people who are working you know
one mr. Bloomberg wasn't you who made
all that money maybe your workers played
some role in that as well to share the
benefits also so Joel what do you think
who got the best of who well look I
think they both got their shots and
particularly later in the night
Bloomberg actually strengthened a bit I
thought he had some good pushback on
Sanders about being the most famous
socialist millionaire in the country at
three houses
that was a good pushback I also think
the fact that bloomers moments were late
in the debate and it matters so much
when these things happen probably you
guys know this is people who are on TV
the the wind viewers are watching the
most matters and that first hour
Bloomberg really got eviscerated so I'd
be curious to see when most people were
watching and when they saw the impactful
attacks maybe that's why it since he had
better moments at the end that his
campaign can come out today and say he
had a fairly you have to win the spin
and that's why winning the special win
here's the thing it was like the NDA
question to Bloomberg though you got to
know this is coming at you they're
talking about capitalism and whether
it's been broken in this debate for
months and
and months here comes somebody who could
have said a given an answer that had
that appealed to the various different
parts of the Democratic coalition and
when I was talking about opening the
door to your candidacy that was an
opportunity for Bloomberg to make the
case about how his wealth gives him some
insight or his time as a boss gives him
some insight and he never really took
that up it was an interesting moment
between Pete Buddha judge and Amy
Klobuchar we pull that that sound to
didn't want to get your take on it
you're staking your candidacy on your
Washington experience you're on the
committee that oversees border security
you're on the committee that does trade
you're literally in a part of the
committee that's overseeing these things
and we're not able to speak to literally
the first thing about the politics of
the country to ourselves are you trying
to say that I'm dumb or are you mocking
me here people sometimes forget names I
am the one that has number one has the
experience based on passing over one
thing so personal we would say this was
this was right after she she was
defending that she couldn't name the
President of Mexico I also might want to
consult Clark Kellogg on that because
that felt like the Midwest Midwestern
bracket for the NCAA tournament I like
the two people who are fighting for the
the heartland bracket and those folks
are going after the same voters who the
judge and Klobuchar are trying to go
after the same chunk of the Democratic
electorate that's why it's gotten so
personal
I think Buddha judges candidacy is
almost it's almost an insult to Amy
Klobuchar
in itself and I certainly seem to what
did you think John well they're yeah
they're not going to be on each other's
Christmas card list today they're
fighting as Joel said they're fighting
for that kind of moderate position we
also have not even talked about Joe
Biden which is something there and and
so at the end of this debate everybody
might have had their little moment
nothing much was resolved in terms of
that portion of the electorate and
they're fighting it out to see who can
be at the top of it that that quote the
debate there got a little down in the
sort of a fact-check or sort of a quiz
show kind of question about whether she
knew and it Elizabeth Warren jumped in
and said this is why this is not
important we should talk about important
things another way in which she asserted
herself in something that was happening
way on the other side of the debate
stage
all right so Donald Trump I can't
remember one memorable moment from
Donald Trump last night and I think
that's what a lot of establishment
hammock rats are gonna be considered his
name's Joel Payne and John Dickerson
you'll have to come back for the sequel
because there will be a sequel CBS News
will co-host that sequel that is the
next Democratic presidential debate in
Charleston South Carolina our very own
Gayle King and Norah O'Donnell will
moderate and they will be joined by
Margaret Brennan major Garrett and Bill
Whitaker of 60 minutes in the
questioning the Congressional Black
Caucus Institute is the co-host and
Twitter is a partner you can see that
debate on Tuesday February 25th at 8:00
p.m. Eastern 7:00 p.m. Central right
here on CBS and CBS n yeah looking
forward to that